switzerland to new zealand have
bilateral veterinary agreements
with the european union and face lower
non-tariff barriers
than the uk despite our very high
standards
with the food and drink federation
reporting a massive drop
in uk food exports over 90 percent in
some areas
and furthermore sps checks cost you in
the main challenge
for the northern protocol surely the
prime minister should be making it a
priority to negotiate a bespoke
uk eu veterinary agreement
thank you very much mr speaker and
that's exactly why we put in the
temporary and technical measures that we
have to
allow uh free trade to continue
across the whole of the uk and it's very
very important for
those who object to the measures that we
have taken that the
the the protocol should uphold
the principle of east-west trade as well
as
as north north south trade and that's
exactly what we're trying to do
the shrimp garden thank you mr speaker
in sussex by the end of this week
we will have delivered one million
covered jabs well my right old friend
joined me
in paying tribute to the local vaccine
heroes
in particular adam doyle and his
leadership in
helsham charlotte luck in upfield and dr
susie pageant in crobar and will the
prime minister agree with me that the uk
success
is built on the confidence that people
have in the fantastic
vaccine technology and should and when
our constituents get contacted for a
vaccination
they should definitely take up the first
available
appointment well they i can certainly
join her
uh my honourable friend and paying
tribute to adam doll and charlotte and
dr susie padgeam for all their efforts
and she's completely right in what she
says about the foundations of the uk's
uh vaccine success and i have my luck my
job on friday mr speaker you've had
uh yours or you certainly have uh but i
i know he's had his uh i
encourage everybody uh everybody to get
it
we now come to leave the opposition
writer multistarver
thank you mr speaker can i start with
joining the prime minister in
his remarks about yesterday's day of
reflection
for the 126 000 people who lost their
lives
to covid that's a shocking number
and behind every one of those numbers is
a grieving family
as soon as restrictions lift there must
be a full
public inquiry because that is the only
way we can get to the bottom of the
many mistakes that were made during the
pandemic and find justice for those
who've suffered
so much mr speaker
why did the prime minister promise at
the last election
that he would and i quote not be cutting
our armed services in any form
mr speaker that was because what we were
going to do was actually
increase spending on our armed services
by the biggest demand since the
uh since the cold war 24 billion pounds
uh modernizing
our armed forces keeping up with no
redundancies mrs b
keeping our our army at 100 000 if you
include the reserves and i must
take you to a slightly amiss from the uh
right honourable gentleman when he stood
on a
a manifesto to elect a man who wanted to
pull this country
out of nato mr speaker
mr speaker he's fighting the last war
but
um is he is
is it is he is he trying
is he trying to pretend is he trying to
pretend
hidden in that answer that the army
stands over a hundred thousand the
number the prime minister
quoted there because it's absolutely
clear from the secretary of state for
defense's statement that i think he made
here on monday he was absolutely clear
his words i have therefore taken the
decision to reduce the size of the army
to 72 500 by 2025.
only this prime minister could suggest
that a reduction from 82 000
to 72 000 is somehow not a cut
but the prime minister didn't answer my
question which was why did he make
that promise he said before the last
election prime minister all we're all
looking up
we will not be cutting our armed
services
in any form what did he do this week
he cut the british army by 10 000. he
cut the number of tanks
he cut the number of planes for our raf
and he cut the number of ships for the
royal
navy i say he the prime minister didn't
have the courage actually to come to the
house himself
to say what he was doing so let me ask
the prime minister a simple question
going back to that promise
before the election did he ever intend
to keep his promise
to our armed forces prime minister
mr speaker not only not only did we uh
keep our promise
uh the of the in the manifesto we
actually increased spending
uh by 14 more than that manifesto
manifesto commitment
and i again mr speaker i think he is
frankly satirical
uh to be lectured about the size of the
uh of the army
when the shadow foreign secretary
herself only recently wrote that the
entire british army should be turned
into a kind of peace call
mr speaker and uh and when as i say the
uh the leader of the of the opposition
stood on a manifesto
uh to elect a elector wanted to elect a
leader
who himself wanted uh to disband
the armed services this is a massive
investment
in our defenses and in our future and
it's wonderful to hear the the new
spirit of
of jingo that seems to have enveloped uh
some of the labor benches
uh you they they they don't like it up
and mr speaker
[Applause]
let's try this for open because um the
prime minister might want to avoid the
promises he made but i
found an interview he gave during the
general election campaign
under the headline here's the headline
no troop cuts
tories will maintain size of armed
forces
it then goes on to quote the prime
minister
boris johnson has promised that he will
not make any new cuts to the armed
forces
he also promised might want to listen to
this prime minister he also promised to
maintain numbers
at their current level including the
army's 82 000.
now i know the prime minister's got
formed for making up quotes
but but can you tell us does he think
the newspapers have somehow misquoted
him
or does he now remember making that
promise
prime minister yes mr speaker because
there have been no redundancies in our
armed forces and i said to him
if you include if you include reserves
and we're even keeping the army
at a hundred thousand but on top of that
mr speaker we're doing what is necessary
to modernize our armed forces taking
them into the 21st century
building more frigates mr speaker
investing in cyber war famously
doing all the difficult things that
labor shirked
during their time in office including mr
speaker modernizing and
upgrading our nuclear deterrent which
again which again
half the shadow front bench would like
to remove
leaving britain defenseless
internationally
[Applause]
mr speaker i have every respect for our
reservists but
the ma the prime minister was just
playing with the numbers he knows
very well that the numbers have been cut
the trouble is you just can't trust the
conservatives to protect our armed
forces
well let let's look
mr speaker let's look at their last
manifestos these are the manifestos that
those opposites stood on
the 20 the 2015 manifesto
order i'm struggling to hear to lead the
opposition
and i will hear the lead of the
opposition so please i want the same
respect to the prime minister i respect
for the leader of the opposition
thank you mr speaker the 2015 manifesto
we will maintain the size of the regular
armed
services the 2017 manifesto
we will maintain the overall size of the
armed forces
2019 the prime minister we will not be
cutting out um
our armed services in any form
but the truth is since 2010 our armed
forces have been cut by
45 000 and our army will now be cut to
its lowest level in 300 years
let me remind the prime minister of
members opposite why this matters
lord richards former chief of defense
staff
has warned that with an armed force of
this size now
we almost certainly wouldn't be able to
retake the falklands
or stop genocide says it's rubbish
that's lord richard's prime minister
after 10 years of conservative
government is the prime minister not
ashamed of that well
mr speaker this conservative government
is massively proud of the investment
that we've made
in our armed forces which i say is the
biggest uplift since the
the cold war and he should look at what
the nato secretary general
had to say about our investment which is
absolutely vital for the future success
of the alliance and indeed uh for the
security of many other countries
around the world a 24 billion pound
investment investment in the future
combat air system and use army uh
special operations
ranger regiment uh 1.3 billion pounds to
upgrade
uh the challenger uh main battle tanks
uh
massive investment in the typhoon
squadrons and so on
we're investing in the future mr speaker
and yes of course we've had to take
some tough decisions but that's because
we believe in our defenses and we
believe that they should be more than
merely
symbolic and it's the labour party mr
speaker who are consistently
historically
hilarious to be lectured about the
falklands mr speaker
consistently uh consistently
weak on protecting this country and you
and you heard it
uh you it was most most visible uh last
week mr speaker during the debate on the
integrated
review when it was playing that the
shadow front
bench couldn't even agree to maintain
britain's
nuclear but nuclear deterrent absolutely
true mr speaker
mr speaker what's weaker than making a
promise to our armed forces just before
the election
then breaking it and not being prepared
to admit it not having the courage
to admit it and there's a pattern here
mr speaker he promised the nhs that they
would have
quotes whatever they need now nurses are
getting a pay cut
he promised a tax guarantee now he's
putting taxes up for families
he promised he wouldn't cut the armed
forces now he's done just that
so if the prime minister is so proud of
what he's doing so determined to push
ahead
why does he at least have the courage to
put this
cut in the armed forces to a vote in
this house
prime minister mr speaker i'm proud of
what we're doing
to increase spending on the armed forces
by the biggest amount
since the cold war the only reason we
can do that mr speaker is because under
this conservative government we've been
running
a sound economy and it's also because we
believe
in defence we've been getting on with
the job he talks about nurses and
investment in
the nhs i'm proud of the massive
investment
uh that we've made uh in the nhs and
actually we have 60
000 more nurses now in training and
we've
increased their starting salary by 12.8
percent
we're getting on with the job mr speaker
of recruiting more police 20
000 more please i think we've done 7 000
already while they're out on the streets
mr speaker
demonstrations shouting kill the bill mr
speaker that's the difference
that's the difference between his party
and my party
we're pro backs mr speaker we're low tax
and when it comes to defense we've got
your backs mr speaker
can i just say i i genuinely mean this i
do not
believe any member of parliament would
support
that kill the bill i've got to be very
careful what
i'd say we are all united in this house
and the support and the protection that
the police offer us
and nobody will shy away from that mr
thank you mr speaker the question prime
minister is why
not put it and i have the courage to put
it to a vote
that question of course was avoided
prime minister mr speaker like
all of the questions and we all know why
he won't put it to a vote
let me quote his conservative mp chair
of the defense select committee
because he recognizes and he has
experience
and respect across the house he
recognizes that this review means
dramatic cuts to our troop numbers
tanks armored fighting vehicles and more
than
a hundred raf aircraft and he goes on to
say
your mp prime minister cuts that if
tested by a
parliamentary vote i do not believe
would pass
not me his own mps
mr speaker can i say this because i want
to turn
to another issue that affects thousands
of jobs in many communities across the
country
5 000 jobs are at risk at liberty steel
with many more in the supply chain the
uk steel industry is under huge pressure
and the government's failure to
prioritize british steel
in infrastructure projects is costing
millions of pounds in investment
so will the prime minister now commit to
working with us
and the trade unions to change this
absurd situation
to put british steel first and do
whatever is necessary
to protect those jobs
mr speaker i'll just remind of course
happy to cooperate in any way but
the steel output halved under the uh
under the labor government
i share very much the anxiety of
families
uh who's uh with of steel workers who
work in in liberty steel and
that's why the uh the my honourable
friend runner from the business
secretary has had
i think three meetings just in the last
few days uh with liberty steele to take
the
uh to take the question forward see what
we can uh we can do we are actively
engaged uh we're investing uh huge sums
in modernizing uh
british steel making british steel uh
plants making them
more environmentally friendly but we
have a massive opportunity
mr speaker because this government is
engaged on a 640
billion pound infrastructure campaign uh
hs2
the great dogger bank uh wind farms uh
hinckley
uh all the things that we're now
building uh the beaching railway
reversals all the things that we're
doing across the country
they will call for millions and millions
of tons
of british steel and now mr speaker
thanks for leaving the european union
we have an opportunity to direct that
procurement at british firms
in the way that we would want to do
whereas i know that the right honourable
gentleman would like nothing
more than to take this country back into
the european union and remove
that opportunity for british steel and
british steel workers
thank you mr speaker last night i spoke
with young people in abercrombie about
their experiences
of 12 months living with lockdowns they
were very articulate
about the challenges they've overcome
and about their concerns for their
future
finding a job moving to a new university
does the prime minister have a message
for evie jonas
saul and lauren who i spoke with and
other young people who are thinking
about their future
and the life after lockdown
yes my message is is just to thank them
and to say
for what they put up with and to say i'm
sorry about how difficult it has been
uh for for their generation i i don't
think
there could be any group of young people
who have been put through much we've had
to sacrifice so much
uh in our in our lifetimes and uh we owe
it to them
to repair their education and to get
them uh into work as fast as we possibly
can
and that's why we've set out the uh the
two billion pound uh kickstart fund and
many other schemes uh which i hope
uh will be useful at his constituents
let's go to the leader of the smp
in blackford ian thank you mr speaker
yesterday my brilliant colleague the
member for adrian shots
made his final speech to this parliament
he is standing for the scottish
parliament
and is doing the right thing by stepping
down as an mp
by doing the right thing he will avoid a
dual mandate and a separate by-election
that would cost the public 175 000
pounds
mr speaker the scottish tory leader
is also seeking a place in the scottish
parliament but is refusing to step down
as an mp
so as his boss well the prime minister
ordered the member for murray to resign
his seat
avoid a dual mandate and save the
taxpayer
175 000 pounds or
are dual mandates one more tory policy
where they think greed is good
prime minister i think my honourable
friend uh uh
the member for marion ross is doing an
excellent job of uh
holding the uh scottish national party
to account for their
manifold uh failings uh not least on
education
uh failing to deliver on crime and
failing in my view to deliver for the
people of
scotland so caught up as as they are uh
in their desire
for for independence and another
referendum and i'm uh for separation i'm
amazed actually that he hasn't
mentioned it so far but perhaps he will
now let's go back to him blackfoot
in
simply yet again a prime minister
failing to answer a question and
that charge that greed is good in the
tory policies mr speaker
we know that tory leaders in scotland
have a habit of dodging democracy
baroness davison is fleeing the house of
lords
and the current tory leader is too
feared
to stand in a constituency no wonder
this morning's daily record declared
that the scottish tories
have exposed themselves as shameless as
nasty
and just plain daft they are led by a
man
so devoid of imagination that when asked
what he would do if he was prime
minister for a day he replied
i would like to see tougher enforcement
against gypsy travelers
does the prime minister really have
confidence in a scottish tory leader
who doesn't even have the courage to put
himself
before the voters in a scottish
constituency
of course mr speaker and uh the right
the right honorable gentleman represents
a party that's so
devoid of imagination uh that he can't
come up with any
workable uh solutions to help the people
of scotland
uh improve their education uh improve uh
the fight against crime
cut taxes in scotland where they're the
highest in the
in the whole of the of the uk they're so
devoid of imagination mr speaker
the one track record uh all they can
talk about is a referendum
uh to break up the united kingdom that's
that's that's their song i'm amazed
that she it's twice he hasn't mentioned
it maybe he's getting nervous
of singing that particular song how do
you know he's rather curious mr speaker
well he's not coming back is he but but
next week let's see
after easter let's see if he remember he
mentions it again
we're okay thank you mr speaker as my
right honourable friend has already said
and the steel industry is fundamental to
our future in the uk
and we can't reach our net zero
commitments or our infrastructure
targets without steel
but stocksbridge speciality steals in my
constituency does have an uncertain
future because of the funding challenges
faced by liberty group and the
stockbridge works is a strategic asset
of national importance
so what assurances can my right
honourable friend give my constituents
that the government will do what it
takes to safeguard jobs and livelihoods
and secure the future of steel making in
the uk
i i thank my honourable friend and she's
a a passionate and
uh successful advocate for her
constituents and for steelmaking
in this country in which this government
passionately believes and that's why
as i was saying to the right honourable
gentleman we're supporting uh the uk
steel industry
uh with uh with more than 500 million of
relief but also uh with
huge investments to make uh our steel
making more
greener and more competitive uh and we
will we will do everything we can mr
speaker
uh to ensure that we continue with uh
british jobs for
producing british steel uh with the
infrastructure investments
that i've mentioned and directing those
of that procurement at british jobs in
the way that we now can
the prime minister talks about restoring
freedoms
as we emerge from the lockdown it is
pushing a bill
that will restrict one of our most
fundamental freedoms
the right to peaceful protest and
peaceful assembly
and tomorrow he is asking for another
blank check
to restrict everyone's freedoms until
september
even though we now know the vast bulk of
the coronavirus act
is not needed to tackle the pandemic
so will the prime minister for once
match his actions
to his words drop these draconian laws
and instead publish a roadmap to revive
civil liberties and freedoms in our
country
i i sympathize very much with his uh
desire to see freedoms restored
and i i i i want to do that as fast as
we possibly can
that's why we've set out the uh the
cautious but we hope irreversible
road map that we have which i hope that
he supports i hope the right honourable
gentleman
uh also supports so you can uh never
tell mr
speaker but what we also want uh to do
is to make sure that uh we're able to
deal with the very considerable backlog
uh that we've faced because of the
pandemic so uh making sure that we have
powers still
uh to accelerate court procedures with
with zoom courts to make sure that we
allow uh allow
volunteers uh to continue to help in the
nhs retired
staff to come back to the colors powers
that are necessary
in education it is it is important to be
able
to continue with those special measures
uh
for the for the months ahead and that's
why we've set out the bill
as we have lucia thank you mr speaker
my constituent tracy felstead is at the
court of appeal today
along with 41 other subpostmasters she
is seeking to clear her name
in a grotesque miscarriage of justice
the post office horizon scandal
the court has heard that the
institutional imperative
to back a flawed i.t system and to
convict
sub-postmasters destroying lives of
decent
men and women in a ruthless
determination
to protect the post office come what
may taxpayers will be picking up the
bill for this multi-million
pound reckless wrongdoing
does the prime minister agree with me
that in order for justice to be truly
done
that those responsible for this failure
and its cover-up
they must be held to account does he
agree that heads
should roll uh well mr speaker we've
certainly
uh i i certainly understand the uh the
uh my honorable friend's
uh strong feelings on this issue and i
and her campaign is one i think that is
uh shared by many members across the
across this house and that's why we
launched the post office
post office horizon i.t inquiry which
has made actually quite fast
progress and yes we do want to learn
the lessons yes we do i want to make
sure that uh the right people
are held to account for what happened
and that the post office
never repeats a mistake like this let's
go to ellen dollars alan
thank you mr speaker and good afternoon
subject to his health and condition
being met
the northern ireland act of 1998 allows
for the secretary of state of northern
ireland to call a referendum
on irish new unification and for
northern ireland to leave the united
kingdom within seven years of a previous
referendum
these conditions for referendum have all
been more than met
in scotland's since independence
referendum in 2014
seven years ago we are allegedly a union
of equal nations
so why is the democrat or the prime
minister not to create a section 30
order
enabling the democratic will the people
of scotland to be measured
is it because he's fearful of the likely
outcome
prime minister mr speaker i knew it
would be long
there they are uh uh the reason mr
speaker
those there's a couple of reasons first
of all as uh
senior members of his party said it was
a once in a generation
uh event in 2014 i think the point of
view that is shared
uh across the uh the house uh and and
quite and quite rightly but but the
other reason uh which is absolutely
plain to most people in this country is
that we're all trying to
uh build back better uh get out of a
pandemic uh and i think that is the
priority
uh for the british people i think it's
the priority for the whole country and i
think they i think
people are frankly amazed uh to hear the
scottish nationalist parties still
in these circumstances banging on about
their constitutional
obsessions all right let's go to
gentlemen
mr speaker scottish rugby legend doddy
weir lives in my constituency and has
been diagnosed with motor neurone
disease
at dory's foundation the my name is
dordi foundation is camping
campaigning alongside the research
community patience mnd scotland and mnd
association
for the government to invest 50 million
pounds over five years to establish a
virtual mnd research institute
now i understand positive discussions
have already taken place with the health
secretary but it's important to ensure
other priorities such as this are not
lost in the pandemic
will the prime minister commit the
government to supporting this initiative
so we can work towards finding a cure
to this devastating disease
i i thank my honourable friend very much
for raising this
uh important question and for uh for
championing research into
into murder neurone disease and uh i
thank him also for raising the excellent
work of the
uh of the my name is dodi uh foundation
and uh we've
we've spent 54 million pounds uh in the
in in the last five years towards
uh this cause mr speaker and we're
looking now
uh to uh ways significantly to boost
uh the research uh that we're supporting
let's go to our absolute calm
absolutely uh mr speaker a year into
this crisis and more than 126
000 lives have been lost behind the
staggering
figure are millions grieving their loved
ones
in my family we have lost an entire
generation i couldn't hold my mom's hand
as she lay dying
and i recently lost both my father and
mother-in-law within just
days of one another grieving families
like mine
want and deserve to understand what
happened
and if anything could have been done to
prevent
this tragedy so will the prime minister
today
commit to launching a full public
enquiry
into the handling of the pandemic as
soon as
current restrictions are lifted
mr speaker i want to say to uh the
honourable gentleman that i know that
the whole house
shares my sympathies and my sorrow
for for your loss for his loss and uh
we sympathize also with your entire his
entire family
mr speaker and i know that uh
his experience is one as he rightly says
that he's been shared by far too many
families
up and down the country and that is why
uh we are of course
committed uh as soon as it's uh right to
do so
as as soon as uh it wouldn't be uh
an irresponsible uh diversion of the
energies of the key
uh officials involved uh we're of course
committed uh to an inquiry
to learn the lessons to make sure uh
that something like this
can never happen again okay just
try and push us through to get through
the list andrew jones
thank you mr speaker on the 3rd of may
wembley is scheduled to host the finals
of the fa vars and fa trophy
not from this season but delayed a year
from the last one but that date means
that no fans can go even though a trip
to wembley to follow their team is like
a holy grail especially for the smaller
clubs
the mps for the clubs involved that's
the members for north west durham
gyro castle point and myself have raised
this with the fa
will the prime minister join us in
encouraging those scheduling the matches
to do all they can to move the date so
that fans can attend
yeah i i hope very much mr speaker that
the
football association would have listened
uh carefully uh to what my honourable
friend has to say and uh
uh they do what they can and i look
forward to to may the 17th
uh when uh spectators uh according to
the roadmap uh may return
ronnie carlos yeah very much mr speaker
17 months ago prime minister
i stood in this place and asked you what
you're going to do to get medical
cannabis to children suffering from rare
forms of epilepsy
and you said to me you recognized their
desperate difficulties
and that you would take it up personally
with me their differences are still
desperate you've not taken this up
personally with me
in the interim we've developed new
medicines distributed around the country
given to people who need them free of
charge why
are we discriminating against the
children what are they are they
worth less than the general public and
the prime minister moved to make medical
cannabis available to children with
epilepsy
and if you could please prime minister
take this of me personally
five minutes of your time today could go
a long long way
well i'm i'm very happy to do whatever
we can to uh
to uh meet with the honorable uh
gentleman and take the matter forward
but the
the dutch government i'm told has uh
confirmed they will allow the continued
supply of bedrock and
oil uh against uk prescriptions uh
until uh at least the summer and the and
the until
until july as he rightly says and i my
rival from the health secretary
is working to find a permanent solution
i have no doubt that we'll be very happy
uh to meet with uh the honourable
gentleman let's go to direct tom
historic
thank you mr speaker given the past 12
months i like many others would not want
the job of prime minister even for all
the tea in china
however the job does give opportunities
to directly improve the lives of people
who are very very sick
march is brain tumor awareness month and
over a hundred thousand people have
signed a brain tumor research petition
calling for the government to match
brain tumor research funding with
other devastating cancers and we know
through kovid that properly funded
research really can bring improved care
treatment and a cure will my friend the
prime minister meet with me to receive
the petition when it is safe to do so
yes indeed mr speaker and i thank him
for what he's doing congratulating what
he's doing to champion
uh research into into brain cancer and
i know from activists in my own
constituency where the center of hope
uh runs the hillingdon uh brain tumor
injury group how vital it is
uh because uh too often people don't
appreciate uh
the number of people who are the victims
of
brain tumors and we've put another 40
million
into brain tumor research and uh
we are certainly going to put more and i
i look forward to meeting
my honourable friend let's go to emma
lewell book
emma thank you very much mr speaker
my constituents ronald and julia
sheriff's daughter danielle currently
lives in gran canaria
last year aged just 33 she suffered an
aneurysm
danielle remains deeply unwell and her
family are crowdfunding to bring her
back home to live
they have been advised that when she
does return home she won't be eligible
for the treatment that she needs on the
nhs
please can the prime minister support
the crowdfund for danny
and give his personal assurance that she
will receive the care
that she needs from our nhs
i thank her very much for raising the
the case and
i my deepest sympathies with uh uh with
danielle and uh
and her her family and we'll make sure
that uh the relevant health
minister uh meets her to discuss the
case as fast as possible right
let's just go to kelly tell us kelly
thank you mr speaker 40 years on from my
predecessor dane peggy fenner's
opposition to the closure
of chatham dockyard with the loss of
thousands of jobs
i am now opposing the closure of what
today is chatham docks
with the loss of over a thousand skilled
jobs this regionally important asset
home to successful marine and
construction businesses all growing
in spite of kobe to make way for flats
short-term profit for the landowner
at the expense of long-term economic and
environmental benefit
does my right honourable friend agree
with me local councillors and the save
chatham docs campaign that coastal
infrastructure
plays a significant role in the growth
of our local economies
creating jobs and clean maritime
technology contributing to our
net zero ambition
yes mr speaker one of the reasons why we
put 24 billion pounds into
defense alone is that it drives 400 000
jobs
around the country uh including the
building of uh of new frigates
uh and new ships of of all kinds and i
hope very much that
uh chattan will benefit from the 100
million funding we put in in
the 24th of december to rejuvenate uh
coastal
uh coastal towns uh the ma the matter
she raises
uh the planning issue she raises is a
matter for the
uh for the local council but i do hope a
solution can be found
uh which gives uh the benefits that she
describes for the local community
let's go to paul blanfield paul
thank you mr speaker last night i met
again
with leaseholders whose lives have been
torn apart
by the cladding and building safety
scandal
now the prime minister will recall that
he told the house on the 3rd of february
and i quote no leaseholder should have
to pay for the unaffordable costs
of fixing safety defects that they did
not cause
and are no fault of their own no ifs no
buts
an unequivocal pledge now the
government's measures so far
fall well short of fulfilling it so
could the prime minister say
now not what has been done but what he
will do
to deliver his promise
uh mr speaker where in addition to the
to the three and a half billion
uh of investment uh that were provided
to to remediate the
the cladding uh and the and the the 1.6
billion that we we've already done we're
providing a new
scheme for leaseholders in in the lower
risk buildings of i think the kind that
he's
describing uh to pay for unsafe
remediation over the long term and
they'll also be a new
levy and tax on developers so that they
also
contribute to the remediation costs so
mike penny thank you very much mr
speaker before the prime minister became
prime minister we had a discussion to do
with the prescribed medical use of
cannabis
and how it was helping to save really
seriously ill children not hundreds
of thousands but about 150
we changed the law in november 2018 to
make it legal
for these prescriptions to be written
descriptions written by top consultants
today we have three children that have
it free
on the nhs and 100 150 children
that have to beg and borrow their
families and remortgage their homes
so that they can actually pay around
about 2 000 pounds a month
promise that this is wrong as a father
like i am you would do everything
possible for your families
and these families are doing everything
possible for their children
can we have a follow-up meeting to the
one in 2018
where i will bring one of the mothers
who actually gets it free
not to stop her getting it free but
allow to explain to the prime minister
how wrong this is that children's lives
are being going to be lost
if we have to go through the process
that the nhs is proposing
well mr speaker the second time i've
asked but i thank my
uh on my right on my friend very much
and he's right to
to raise it uh and uh we will make sure
that uh we have a a proper meeting with
the
uh with the department of health uh so
that we can resolve
the issue of how to make sure that the
bedrocan or the uh
the uh the cannabis-based products that
are coming uh from holland
uh that supply uh can be made uh secure
and can
and can continue don butler thank you
very much
mr speaker mr speaker can i personally
thank you for your support for
parliament's uh kovid memorial quilt uh
prime minister after
uh pm keys i will be presenting my cross
party
private members bill the coronavirus
number two bill
to parliament it's based on scientific
advice
sage guidance and lessons learned will
the prime minister please commit to
reading this bill
and please provide me with response a
written response
maybe by tomorrow i know that's a bit of
a long answer but if not
within the next two weeks thank you
i'm very happy to make that commitment
mr speaker
thank you mr speaker to thank you mr
speaker to paraphrase
um the late great much missed eric iv
uh mr speaker i believe in individual
freedoms
and individual responsibility i believe
that individuals make better decisions
for themselves
their families and their communities
than the state
makes for them i loathe the nanny state
and i believe in cutting taxes prime
minister
am i still a conservative
yes mr speaker let's go to
dave duggan dave
mr speaker we learned today
unfortunately from the media rather than
a minister that the treasury has
informed the veterans office that their
budget is to be cut by 40
from 5 million to 3 million now this
cannot be right mr speaker it's just
yesterday
graham day the snp scottish government's
veterans minister
announced a further 1 million pounds to
support scottish veterans alone
these disparate positions are
irreconcilable this is a tale of two
governments
so will the prime minister follow the
snp's lead and assure the house today
that he will not allow
this cut to uk funding for veterans
prime minister
not only was this the first government
to create a veterans minister
specifically with the charge of uh
looking after veterans mr speaker we've
not only have we invested in them uh but
we've also taken steps to protect
our armed service veterans from
vexatious litigation
pursued by lefty lawyers mr speaker
of a kind sitting not a million miles
away from me today
who pursue them long after long after
they have served that served queen and
country
and when no new evidence has been
provided we tried to protect them
mr speaker we have protected them and
that party voted against it mr speaker
let's go to andrew bridgen andrew
bridgen
thank you mr speaker uh the prime
minister has always enjoyed his visits
to my constituency of northwest
leicestershire whether it's ashby de la
zeus on the eve of the historic
referendum or
castle rock school coalville last august
he will therefore be pleased but not
surprised that
uh leicestershire county council for the
last three years has been the most
productive
county authority in the country despite
also being the lowest funded
can my right onward friend assure all
the residents of leicestershire
that our conservative control county
council will imminently benefit from
fairer funding and the government's
leveling up agenda
so that it can continue to deliver
excellent public services
yes mr speaker i thank uh leicestershire
county council for
uh the way they're uh conducting
themselves and for delivering
value for money and that is what uh the
elections that are
coming up in may are all going to be
about mr speaker invariably these
conservatives who deliver better value
or deliver better services and lower
taxes and that is
uh what leicestershire county council
has done and i congratulate them
on it and i fully agree with what my
honorable friend has said
crystal very very grateful mr speaker
the government has said that the
community renewal fund
is a fantastic opportunity for wales
yet bridgend county is not listed as a
priority place for the fund
and on the 10th of february at the
dispatch box the prime minister
invented and i quote a world-leading
battery plant
for bridgeend in response to the
significant job losses we've faced
across my county borough
in the last two years except when the
prime minister has still refused to
apologize to my constituents
for when will he stop treating my
constituents as an afterthought
keep true to his promise of not a penny
less for wales
and ensure that he brings real
investment to my constituents
in
across wales uh the people of wales and
the welsh government will receive an
additional
5.2 billion pounds of resource funding
on top of the spring budget funding of
20 2021
800 million of the leveling up fund is
going to
uh the devolved nations and each local
authority in wales
each local authority in wales will
receive 125 000
pounds in capacity funding and i look
forward to working with him
and with welsh local government to
deliver those improvements
that's the final question i'm now
suspending the house for three
minutes to enable the necessary
arrangements before we start the next
business order
three minutes suspension while the house
prepares for a statement on the new
immigration proposals from the
government we're expecting the home
secretary pretty patel
uh to do that with me are uh political
editor beth rigby and beth there
rather sharper exchanges between boris
johnson and kiersten than we've been
used to
yeah to pardon the pun but kirsten there
really put in his own tanks
on boris johnson's lawn over the issue
of army
cuts it's not comfortable labour
territory it's not typical
labor territory it's in fact labor
territory that kierstama knows he's
pretty weak on which is
the armed services and defense but he
really laid into the prime minister on
those
army cuts the manifesto pledge was very
clear there would be no cuts
to armed services in any form
it's on camera the prime minister saying
that at a press conference
and in the manifesto and of course in
the command paper
this week the government announced that
the army target size will be cut by nine
and a half thousand
to seventy two and a half thousand uh
people by 2025 it's it's lowest level
since 17 14.
he's spending more the government is
spending more and what about the reserve
and that's right and and and the
government you know what we saw in the
command paper is
that the government is shifting its
resource and actually
it's moving it uh away from
the armed services to other areas where
they want to invest more in
whether that be technology or indeed you
know most noticeably that
that decision to increase the level of
which we could have
uh nuclear warheads there were shifting
in spending but the point being
that he made a pledge not to cut army
numbers
and there he did it so that was quite
uncomfortable
for boris johnson and the way he tried
to deal with kierstarma was he kind of
invoked
his predecessor jeremy corbyn and spoke
of jeremy corbyn's opposition to nato
for example
and kierstama just uh hit backs there
saying you're fighting the last war
trying to again put some clear water
between
kierstama's leadership and
jeremy corbyn's leadership because we
know that this is an area
where labour know that they have a
particular problem with voters should
say that
uh that session ran on rather longer
than usual nearly three-quarters of an
hour um that's because mps are actually
taking a break now there won't be a
pnq's next week or the week after i
think
no we're going we're going into easter
recess now so there's a couple of weeks
off i was a bit surprised it ran on for
that long because the new speaker
lindsay hall has been much more tight on
time hasn't he in pmqs but yeah it ran
over
quite a bit though also very
controversial by the speaker standing up
and saying
after boris johnson had accused labour
of supporting kill the bill
saying no one in this house supports
kill the bill well
there is going to be opposition isn't
there to the police bill
there is going to be opposition but i
think what has happened in the commons
is that
after some of the uh unpleasant
exchanges
the anger on the street certainly the
speaker there is just trying to
dial down and the torch is also the
ambiguity of the word the bill
which exactly can mean exactly it can
mean
and we saw what happened uh in bristol
and that is certainly something i think
all
mps want to step back from and dial down
now uh it is going to be the home
secretary who's going to
make the statement they're still uh
waiting to get
ready uh anything else that struck you
in pmq's today
well i think the other thing that is the
obvious elephant in the room that will
not go away which was raised twice in
pnq's and by kierstama
is when is the government going to
announce the public inquiry
uh over covered the prime minister again
saying i'll do it when the time is right
he still doesn't want to put a date on
it but i imagine that the pressure will
only build as we come out
of the lockdown the vaccine program is
rolled out
um and you know where when is he going
to announce that
okay let's go now to the statement on
immigration from the home sector
mr speaker i wish to make a statement on
our new plan for
immigration the government has taken
back control of